depuis que les hommes étaient les
siennes et les données vidéo l'histoire
de l'aviation
la conquête du ciel le temps des
pionniers
depuis le premier jour de la création
scrutant le ciel l'homme regarder les
nuages dérivés majestueusement vers un
horizon inconnue et les oiseaux s'est
levé dans l'immensité immaculé l'homme
rêvé de connaître les joies mystérieuse
catch et au delà des confins de
l'étendue terrestre pour s'évader
les premiers rêveur dû se satisfaire de
mythes comme celui de dédale et icare
avec leurs gènes de plumes et de cire et
celui d'elijah s'élevant dans les cieux
sur un tourbillon de chevaux ardents
le kit que l'humanité existe
le ciel est le domaine du terrain il
symbolise la liberté le pouvoir de
contrôler les choses aient la
possibilité de citer tous nés de pères
et de goûter à la liberté chez certains
la petite aventure demande est plus que
limitée des légendes
il ne se contentait pas d'imaginer
simplement l'exaltation que volet
pourrait procurer il voulait ressentir
la liberté de flotter dans les nuages
connaître le bonheur caché dans le monde
inconnu de la lumière solaire et de la
solitude
je vole pour contempler la beauté et
pour perfectionner mes aptitudes que je
recherche en fait repérer réussir à la
prochaine je sens le faire fuir et
l'accompagner pendant un certain temps
pour moi ça c'est plus de découvrir que
de se dépasser
c'est une sorte de quête
de lait remonte au drame midi tard après
103 de soleil xxl fixant ainsi les
grands inventeurs du moyen-âge
s'accrochèrent passerelle définir des
gros types de machines volantes qui ne
marchaient pas m le rêve de dépasser les
limites de ce qui nous entoure
seule l'imagination pouvait permettre
aux premiers rêveur de voyager dans les
airs leurs machines volantes tenait plus
de la foi et de l'imagination que de la
science léonard de vinci fut le premier
au xvème siècle a tempéré l'imagination
avec des principes scientifiques les
carnets de ce grand artiste et grands
inventeurs contiennent des croquis
détaillé d'elle mécanique et de machines
volantes
on y trouve aussi ceux d'un parachute et
d'un hélicoptère
pendant les siècles qui suivirent les
premières réflexions de léonard de vinci
sur les machines volantes ce rêve
immémoriale continua de tourmenter les
esprits aventureux certain imaginaire
des engins qui plus léger que l'air
ambiant flotter comme les nuages avec le
vent
d'autres pensent faire à des machines
plus lourde que l'air qui s'élevait au
dessus des champs et des forêts battant
des ailes comme les oiseaux 200 ans
après léonard de vinci
un prêtre jésuite francesco de l'âne a
conçu un bateau aérien muni d'une voile
soulevé par quatre ballons aux parois de
cuivre très fine
l'idée de l'anah était irréalisable mais
il fit avancer le rêve d'un pas de plus
vers la science
en avignon
au début des années 1780 un papetier
nommé joseph montgolfier pensa que l'on
pouvait peut être utilisé la force qui
soulève la fumée et les cendres dans une
cheminée pour faire monter des objets
dans les airs il allume à un feu et mis
un sac de soie fine au dessus ce qui se
passa en ce jour de novembre 1782 allait
changer le monde à jamais
en 1783 montgolfier et son frère etienne
syrte une démonstration de leur machine
aérostatique à versailles devant le roi
louis xiii la reine marie antoinette et
la cour les premiers passagers envoyés
dans les airs par le ballon des deux
frères furent un mouton un coq et un
canard
quelques temps après le premier humain
fait à son tour l'expérience du vol en
ballon
c'est françois pilâtre de rozier qui eu
cet honneur le 15 octobre 1783
il resta en l'air dans un ballon captif
pendant presque quatre minutes et demie
puis le 21 novembre de la même année
pilâtre de rozier et le marquis
d'arlempdes effectué le premier vol
libre
l'air du vol en montgolfière avait
commencé et l'humanité avait réalisé son
rêve flotter dans les nuages
c'est la seule façon de voler ou non
d'un tel contrôle et un tel contact avec
le milieu ambiant
quand vous traversez indien hal gill et
là dans la nasa avec vous c'est une
façon de voler à la fois très simple et
très pur
ça monte à la tête de se retrouver là au
thon ressemble plus léger plus clair
plus propre et plus bleu c'est comme une
histoire d'amour qui vous prend et qui
dure aussi longtemps que vous restez en
verre
au début l'arrivée sur ti vct d'une
montgolfière dans les campagnes était un
phénomène si surprenant que les premiers
voyageurs en bas l'ont emporté des
bouteilles de vin pour prouver à leur
atterrissage qu'il venait bien de la
terre et non d'un autre monde de la fin
du xviiie siècle jusqu'à la première
moitié du 19e les montgolfières se
répandirent dans le monde mais de plus
en plus de rêveurs n'était pas satisfait
de se trouver à la merci des caprices du
vent ils continuèrent à réfléchir sur le
vol d'engins plus lourd que l'air non
seulement ils désiraient monter dans les
airs comme avec une montgolfière mais il
voulait aussi contrôler ce mouvement
gracieux à la manière des oiseaux
des êtres humains auraient pu voler bien
avant qu'ils ne l'ont fait l espèce de
bois qui est nécessaire et être à
disposition des égyptiens et les accords
ceux qui n'avaient pas c'est la tournure
d'esprit nécessaires pour assembler ces
différents matériaux afin d'en faire une
machine la manière de voler la plus
évidente tombé de battre mais ce n'est
pas une manière de voler ce n'est qu'au
19e siècle que la conception d'engins
elle fixe apparue vraiment avec des
systèmes séparés pour le contrôle et la
propulsion c'est alors que tout a
véritablement commencé ce désir
irrépressible de voler dans les
premières années du 19e siècle avec des
hommes entre 1796 et 1853 un bar aux
nerfs anglais sorte qu'elle est conçu
plusieurs modèles de planeur qui annonce
l'avion tel que nous le connaissons
aujourd'hui
il construisit aussi est testa le
premier planeur grandeur nature
l'un de ces engins les plus célèbres su
piloter pour la première fois par son
cocher après un atterrissage assez
brutal sur la pelouse dans le yorkshire
le coach et lui dit j'ai été engagé pour
rouler pas pour voler et il démissionna
immédiatement de son emploi de cocher
chez third world
en 1842 williamson et john stringfellow
firent breveter un engin volant à vapeur
mais comme bien d'autres auparavant
leurs procédés ne fut pas expérimenté en
1875 thomas small fit construire un
engin à vapeur on raconte que la machine
s'est élevée dans l'air pendant quelques
secondes
mais ce n'était toujours pas un vol
en 1889 l'ingénieur allemand otto
lilienthal publia un ouvrage de renom le
vol des oiseaux comme fondement de
l'aviation lilienthal combinent à ce
qu'ils avaient appris de l'étude du vol
des oiseaux
avec son expérience de l'aérodynamique
il entreprit une série complète
d'expérimentation avec des planeurs
grandeur nature
en 1896 il avait effectué plus de 2000
vol en planeur les exploits de celui que
certains considèrent comme le premier
grand pilote de planeur se répandirent
dans le monde et devait influencer des
pionniers de l'aviation tels que octave
chanut tu es les frères wright
comme il l'a écrit lilliand talent était
convaincu que pour réussir un pilote
doit entrer en relation intime avec le
vent l'année la forme de vol la plus
pure la simple et la plus naturelle en
descend une gorge
on longe paroisse on se sent bien on
ressent la force du nos demandes la
force de la gravitation
on entend le bruit du vent qui change on
voit l'horizon kader et la paroisse se
rapprocher puis s'éloigner il ya un côté
artistique
certains se contentent de piloter
d'autres pilotes et sont aussi artiste
l'ailier n'daw fabriquer ces élégants
planeur avec du bois de saule et de la
toile il fabrique a aussi deux engins à
moteur expérimentaux mais il ne vécut
pas assez longtemps pour expérimenter
ces derniers engins le dimanche 9 août
1896 son planeur décrocha s'écrasa et il
mourut de ses blessures
ses derniers mots furent il faut faire
des sacrifices en 1890 un français
clément ader s'éleva à 20 cm au-dessus
du sol sur une distance record de 50
mètres à bord de son monoplan eole mais
il ne s'agissait toujours pas d'un vol
contrôler ni maintenu en 1894 soeur ira
maxime construisit un énorme biplan
propulsée par deux moteurs à vapeur de
180 chevaux
on raconte que l'engin s'est soulevée
dans les airs avec son équipage soit une
charge de 3 tonnes et demie bien que
captifs et non contrôlés ni maintenu on
aurait pu considérer cela comme une
victoire provisoire sur la gravité à
l'aube du 19e siècle les rêveurs était
finalement parvenue aux premiers
balbutiements du gol à moteur une
compétition cet effet deux jours pour
être le premier à réaliser un vol
contrôlée est maintenu et s'aventurer
ainsi par son propre pouvoir au royaume
de l'aigle et 10 faucon
en 1903 l'un des savants américains les
plus éminents samuel pierre ponk
l'anglais s'apprêtait à faire décoller
son engin depuis un bateau sur le
potomac dans la ville de washington
lange avait une envergure de 15 m il
était propulsé par un moteur radial de
52,4 chevaux il était piloté par son
assistant charles manley mais après la
mise en marche des moteurs le câble de
la catapulte de lancement se rompit il
eut à 20 carmes terrible et l'engin
disparus engloutis par les flots sous le
regard désespéré du pauvre l'anglais
c'est ainsi qu'est shu est une autre
tentative comme le rappelle l'histoire
c'est d'honneur devait revenir à deux
jeunes et talentueux fabricant de
bicyclettes inconnu wilbur et orville
ouailles
se sont intéressés aux vols entre 1896
et 1890 année ils ont beaucoup lui ai
beaucoup réfléchi sur le sujet ils ont
fini par mettre au point un système de
contrôle efficace
ils ont conçu et fabriqué deux planeurs
en 1900 et l'autre en 1901
aucun ne fonctionna de la manière prévue
mais ils ont préféré se remettre à
chercher plutôt que d'abandonner
les frères wright appliquée aux vols
mécanique pilotée une approche
différente de celle des chercheurs de
leur époque
il travaillait non seulement sur la
possibilité de faire s'élever un engin
mais il étudie aussi la possibilité de
le contrôler une fois en l'air nous
sommes le 17 décembre 1903 à quito en
caroline du nord
il fait un froid de canard et le vent
souffle du nord à 43 kilomètres heures à
10 heures du matin
les frères wright décident d'effectuer
le premier d'une série de quatre essais
à 10h30
il met le moteur en marche
orville monte prendre le pilotage à
10h35
il libère l'est au plane du filin qui le
retient et commence à se déplacer avec
le vent
ce premier vol durera 12 secondes après
deux autres essais réussis
les frères wright ce après terre pour le
quatrième vol de la journée
l'engin resta en l'air pendant 59
secondes avec wilber aux commandes et
parcourent une distance de 255 m presque
huit fois celle parcourue à leur premier
essai pour la première fois de
l'histoire une machine transportant un
homme s'étaient élevées dans l'air par
elle même et avait effectué un vol
contrôlée est maintenue ce qui
différencie les frères wright de tous
ceux qui avaient essayé de faire la même
chose auparavant
c'est une totale confiance en eux mêmes
une fois qu'ils étaient convaincus de
quelques sourires ce que les autres
pensent et n'avait plus aucune
importance il avait entière confiance
dans leur propre capacité et dans les
solutions qu'il trouvait ce qui les
différencie aussi c'est leur
extraordinaire faculté conception
d'imaginer ce à quoi devait ressembler
une machine avant qu'elles ne soient
fabriqués et comment elle réagirait
soumise à différentes phases en outre il
avait de nombreuses qualités humaines la
détermination
l'entêtement à ne pas se laisser arrêter
par un problème une vision claire la
faculté de laisser de côté tout un tas
de choses inutiles pour aller droit au
coeur des problèmes tout cela donnait un
résultat
la presse américaine sceptiques ne
rendit que très vaguement compte des
travaux des frères wright
elle se méfiait des fausses annonces de
vols réussis
les nouvelles de leurs progrès n'a tenir
l'europe que d'une manière vague et
incomplètes
le 23 octobre 1906 à bagatelle
le brésilien santos dumont effectua
officiellement un vol d'une longueur de
60 mètres
le fringant petit brésilien fut saluée
comme le conquérant désert le premier
homme ayant réussi à voler il n'a pris
que par la suite qu'il avait été devancé
de trois ans par les frères wright
à l'époque du premier vol de santos
dumont les frères wright venait déjà
régulièrement leur appareil était le
premier capable de rester en l'air sous
contrôle
aussi longtemps que le lui permettaient
sa réserve de carburant
la période comprise entre 1906 et 1916
fut une période de progrès
extraordinaires dans le domaine de
l'aviation
en six mois d'août 1908 à janvier 1909
wilbur wright effectué à plus de 100
vols et d'ablis 103 record du monde
celui du plus long vol en solitaire un
peu plus de 2h20 celui du plus long vol
transportant à passagers et celui de la
plus haute altitude atteinte 113 m
mais les records ne furent pas le seul
héritage laissé par les ex fabricant de
bicyclettes
aéroplan militaire des frères wright qui
vola en 1909 fut le premier appareil
être propriété d'un état est le premier
appareil militaire c'était un véritable
avion pourrait décoller voler pendant 30
ou 40 minutes à écrire des cercles
deviner
en 1908 glenn curtiss un mécanicien
américain ancien coureur motocyclistes
fit ses débuts dans l'aviation
au début ces appareils étaient financées
par les contributions de la femme d'un
autre rêveur célèbre alexandre graham
bell à l'association pour la recherche
expérimentale aérienne
les premiers aviateurs venaient de tous
les horizons c'était des gens comme
glenn curtiss qui à l'instar des frères
wright était des constructeurs des
concepteurs lénk artistes et champion du
monde de vitesse motocycliste
il connaissait mon moteur et savait en
tirer le maximum
et il a tiré le maximum de son mât
viable volet était une idée fixe pour
lui il effectue un vol célèbre tous les
permis de poursuivre cette activité
c'était le vol reliant d'albanie à new
york
ce vol lui rapporta quelque chose comme
dix mille dollars
le 25 juillet 1909 à calais un autre
pionnier de l'aviation louis blériot se
levant avant l'aube
monta dans son monoplan le blériot 11 et
se mit en route pour les falaises
blanches de douvres
37 minutes plus tard le français
effectue à un des atterrissages
fracassant dont il était coutumier mais
il avait traversé la manche est gagnée
le prix de 1000 livres offerts par lord
f cliffs au premier qui réussirait cet
exploit
la plupart des meilleurs pilotes du
monde se rassembler un mois plus tard à
reims pour la première coupe gordon
bennett
plus de deux cent mille billets furent
vendus pour assister à cette réunion
aérienne et auxquels s'ajoutèrent cent
mille spectateurs qui regardaient
évoluer les avions depuis les collines
avoisinantes
tous ces gens venaient assister aux
exploits de pilotes comme glenn curtiss
blériot farman latham et des autres
héros de cette nouvelle ère
le monde dans cet open de l'ère de la
voiture à cheval il y avait une certaine
méfiance pour tous ceux qui volent est
les gens n'avaient même pas confiance
dans l'automobile si vous regardez les
vieux livres vous verrez qu'il y avait
des voitures à cheval autour des
terrains d'aviation les pilotes arrivent
et à tous de cheval ou en carriole et
sauté dans leurs appareils
mon père a fait distribuer le courrier
en voiture à cheval
il a connu l'ère des scouts nique ce fut
une époque sensationnel un livre
où qu'ils aillent les aviateurs attiré
des foules énormes l'avion exercé une
fascination générale
plus d'un million de personnes se
pressaient en 1909 pour voir wilbur
wright voler au dessus de manhattan et
autour de la statue de la liberté
même le président teddy roosevelt ne put
résister à l'attraction du ciel il monta
à bord d'un biplan wright pour goûter le
frisson du baptême de l'air
pour bien des pionniers de l'aviation
volet n'était plus suffisant en soi
seule la maîtrise du vol comptait chaque
vol de 20 bientôt la recherche d'un
autre horizon chaque nouveau pilote rêvé
de voler plus haut et plus vite que les
précédents de dépasser pour la première
fois une autre barrière de la nature
3m est monté par deux préfets sont de
plus en plus de gens s'intéressaient à
l'aviation
si bien qu'en 1910 le new york world lui
consacra un reporter à temps plein
l'un des premiers vétérans de l'aviation
commença à former des volontaires qui
souhaitent s aventurer dans ce monde
nouveau qui s'ouvre est elle s'est
intéressée à l'aviation à l'âge de 4 ans
et demi en 1910 quand glenn curtiss a
descendu l'hudson dans un petit bilan
construit comme un serveur et s'est posé
dans le champ en face de notre ferme
pour faire le plein ce jour là que j'ai
perdu tout intérêt pour les locomotives
à vapeur et que j'ai décidé que plus
tard je serai pile la plupart des avions
de l'époque ne pouvais emporter qu'une
personne
il existait une école d'aviation dans
laquelle il y avait des instructeurs qui
ne pouvons pas voler suivez l'avion le
long de la piste et hurler ses
instructions aux élèves
il fallait d'abord réussir à voler d'un
bout à l'autre du terrain et quand on
commençait à maîtriser l'avion ou
quitter le terrain pour parcourir de
plus grandes distances
il ya des cas où les pilotes ayant
quitté le terrain
continuer tout droit sur un kilomètre au
sur 15 car il ne réussissait pas à faire
demi tour posé dans un champ et tournai
l'avion dans l'autre direction
une re décoller pour rentrer c'est
vraiment
parmi les nouveaux pilotes il y avait un
nombre non négligeable de femmes comme
routes l'eau mêlée busy il dit il est
catherine stinson harriet quimby et
mathilda moisan co navigation est apparu
les femmes ont compris qu'elle devait y
prendre leur place dès le début pour ne
pas être laissées en marge comme elle
l'avait été de tout ce que les hommes
contrôlent et elles se sont dit que s'il
entrait tout de suite ça devrait
accepter au même titre que tous les
fondateurs
à travers toute l'amérique les gens se
précipitaient par milliers pour voir des
démonstrations aériennes lincoln bitchy
l'un des pilotes d'exhibition ayant le
plus de panache captiva l'attention du
public ont dit qu'ils totalisent a au
cours de sa carrière
un millier de loopings et 17 millions de
spectateurs dans 36 villes différentes
parmi les attractions les plus célèbres
de son spectacle il y avait une course
entre lui et des coureurs automobiles
aussi patente et que ai dit rich and
baker et barney oldfield mais les
pilotes d'exhibition de l'avant-guerre
vivait rarement assez longtemps pour
profiter de leur retraite ils ne
pensaient qu'à voler quel que soit le
danger en 1915 plusieurs parmi les
premiers héros de l'aviation s'était
écrasé au sol dont lincoln bitchy et
harriet quimby
lors d'une exhibition à boston le
passager de son blériot se pencha trop
en avant ce qui fit piquer l'avion
le passager tomba de l'avion et le
blériot bascula projetant mademoiselle
quimby sur le sol elle faisait partie
des plus brillants pilotes
elle avait été la première femme à avoir
traversé la manche mais l'on ne la
reverrait plus jamais s'aventurer dans
les airs
l'esprit des pilotes d'exhibition des
débuts de l'aviation
ce désir de faire partager leurs
émotions à tout un pays est toujours
vivant les pilotes d'exhibition sont
aujourd'hui à la pointe de la
technologie moderne mais leur amour du
pilotage est le même que celui de leurs
prédécesseurs
je ne me sens jamais vraiment bien s'il
n'ya pas d'un avion dans les environs
j'ai déjà fait l'expérience
cela ne va pas j'ai l'impression d'être
un peu gras je m'en fais pas il m'arrive
d'avoir des coups de cafard en hiver dès
que j'approche de mon avion
je vais mieux tout va bien je suis
quelqu'un qui fait de la voltige de
précisions certains appellent ça de la
cascade mais une cascade c'est quelque
chose qu'on fait une seule fois mais où
nous faisons de la voltige de précision
de l'acrobatie aérienne pur au sens
strict du terme quotidiennement
vous
on peut nous appeler acrobates
cascadeurs casse-cou peu importe je sais
que je suis sur terre pour voler et
faire partager mon rêve et ma part de
magie je suis né pour faire de la
voltige
le rêve d'un siècle et est devenu une
réalité
on était déjà en train de remplacer les
engins qui quelques années auparavant
n'existait que dans les esprits par
d'autres machines plus performantes
des engins qui permettrait à l'homme de
s'élever encore plus haut dans les cieux
mais le temps ne fit pas oublier les
premiers pour autant il existe
aujourd'hui des refuges pour ces
merveilleuses machines du début de
l'aviation
et pour ceux qui les pilotes et les
maintiennent en état
avec m
j'ai tellement de choses formidables
dans ses voeux en est il de la nostalgie
de la liberté dans tueurs sont les
témoins du combat de l'homme contre les
éléments
quand on est là où on se bat avec son
moteur son avion avec les turbulents aux
abords d'un avion qui a des roues à
rayons un vieux moteur diesel en toile
et en tissu pour la fabriquer soi même
c'est un ensemble de choses attrayante
ses avions étaient fabriqués à partir de
matériaux organiques
les montants sont en bois les ailes en
toile
tous ces matériaux ont existé sous forme
de matière vivante le lin coton etc
pour moi en tant qu'artiste ces avions
sont un peu quelque chose de vivant dont
on finit par faire partie soi-même
sommes pas des assemblages de plastique
et d'acier avec lesquels on n'a aucune
relation
cet avion est un an bio 1 orion 1910
c'est une réplique le fuselage ressemble
à celui d'une cellule de course
il est très léger très résistant les
ailes sont celles du blériot
on les manie avec cette manette là c'est
comme ça qu'on contrôle la stabilité ça
c'est le manche à balai c'est avec ça
qu'on fait piquer l'avion s'était
l'engin le plus perfectionné de l'époque
les pilotes ne testait pas le matériel
comme ils le font aujourd'hui il monte
dedans il volé une fois avec et si ça se
passait bien il adopter
à l'époque dès débuts il y avait un
champ d'aviation dans ma ville en
regardant les pilotes et les avions on
se rendait bien compte que les pilotes
étaient des faux j'ai trouvé que les
avions étaient magnifiques
et quand je pouvais les voir en vol
c'était encore mieux
les pilotes étaient des fous mais les
avions étaient magnifiques
c'est ce qu'ont dû penser ce qu'ils ont
vu les premiers pilotes confié leur sort
au gré du vent
rêveur excentrique savant intrépide
ces gens venaient de tous les horizons
mais ils étaient tous fermement
convaincu que l'humanité ait des fêtes
pour voler
je
en avril 1917 les états unis entrèrent
dans la première guerre mondiale
le président woodrow wilson avait
déclaré qu'il fallait que le monde
devienne un lieu sûr pour la démocratie
au cours de l'année précédant cette
déclaration historique
un petit groupe d'aviateurs américain
volontaires formèrent l'escadrille
d'observation aérienne la faille est
destiné à aller combattre en france mais
ce n'est que deux ans plus tard en mai
1918 que les pilotes et les avions
militaires américains participaient aux
combats aériens au dessus de la france
c'étaient des gars de 18 19 20 ans
piloter ses avions et en juger par les
comptes rendus que j'ai lu les manies
assez crânement il faisait des trucs que
je ne me permettrais jamais il était
jeune elle était précédent décompte il
avait hâte de partir bien sûr c'était
dur quand l'un d'entre eux ccravh et
messi passer le cap des premiers vols
environ un mois 1,2 alors ils
commençaient à maîtriser leur appareil
il accumulé de l'expérience il fallait
qu'elles apprennent vite
vous avez alors de bien meilleures
chances de survie
bien que les vols de reconnaissance
reste la mission essentielle des pilotes
les deux camps commencèrent à développer
des appareils spécialisés pour le combat
qui s'affrontaient en groupe ces
affrontements donné lieu à des duels des
combats singuliers aux commandes de
machines comme l'albatros le newport le
stade
le soft quiz kamel des noms qui nous
rappellent encore aujourd'hui une époque
héroïque
pendant la première guerre mondiale
les débuts se sont faits avec de vrais
cerf-volant crise fabriquée avec du bois
et de la fifa puis avec les progrès dans
les domaines de la vitesse et de la
maniabilité de l'altitude
on a pu construire un avion comme
l'albatros qui était vraiment un
appareil de combat utilisés
certains avions été meilleurs que
d'autres
la wru 500 cas il était un des meilleurs
un avion magnifique conte qui ont un peu
de coordination et de sens mécanique
peut apprendre à le piloter en moins de
quatre heures c'est ce qui se passait
dès qu'on se met aux commandes
et si on sait maintenir à cap il s'élève
doucement
quels progrès de labro 504 aussi puisque
hamel c'est complètement différent
c'était un avion très sensible avec une
maniabilité extrême anadiou magnifique
et pour quelqu'un qui veut et appris à
voler sur 1 ha bro 504 en quatre heures
se retrouver dans le cockpit d'assaut
puisque hamel c'était un sacré
changement
la guerre aérienne avait engendré ces
légendes les premiers as du ciel le
français rené fonck le canadien billy
bishop et ses 72 victoires
le baron rouge l'allemand manfred von
richthofen et les américains raul ou
berri et le capitaine eddy rickenbacker
chaque camp us aisance en france il ya
eu charles nungesser
surnommé l'homme de fer mais georges
guynemer en allemagne il ya eu von
richthofen jude est werner vol tous sont
des aviateurs c'était d'excellence et
cote
certains étaient montés d'autres étaient
de bons chasseurs comme von richthofen
il ne lâchait pas si froid alors que
d'autres si l'homme se servait plutôt
des possibilités techniques de leurs
appareils
les survivants de la grande guerre
revinrent avec leur amour de l'aviation
il avait dans le sang mais la paix est
en revenus on n'avait plus besoin
d'avions de combat les pilotes pouvaient
s'offrir de vieux dh 4 ou de vieux
curtis génie pour trois fois rien il
leur suffisait de faire disparaître
l'emblème de l'armée pour aller se
produire dans tout le pays où proposer
des excursions
il menait une vie difficile et
quelquefois dangereuse mais nous étions
des pilotes
à 10h le ciridd le ciel nous appartenait
et ça nous suffisait
à 17 ans j'avais lu plus de livres sur
l'aviation
la motor les avions et le pilotage que
de livres d'école un été j'ai travaillé
pour un pilote d'exhibition j'ai vendu
des billets pour lui je n'ai et d
entretenir son avion qui était
complètement dingue et j'ai commencé à
apprendre à voler tous s'est étendue ni
canadien de la première guerre est
jamais ça c'était vraiment risqué et je
disposais d'un livre que j'avais étudié
info c'est par m'entraîner en faisant
rouler l'avion pendant un mois lorsque
j'étais capable de faire
j'ai traversé le terrain et j'ai appris
un jour j'ai cru que j'allais rentrer
dans le mur qui se trouvait de l'autre
côté il a fallu que je déconne j'ai dû
mettre une heure et demie à deux heures
avant de me poser après plusieurs
tentatives il se présentait comme des
voltigeurs des hommes et des femmes qui
voulaient simplement pour le plaisir des
milliers de prospectus qui proposait aux
gens de les pendre dans un champ de la
région et de les emmener faire un tour
pour un dollar ça faisait venir une
foule énorme
le trouve dur et très peu de temps pour
en faire 250 ou 300 50 par jour il
fallait
parce que ça dure plus de 35 secondes je
décollais je virais je revenais je
recommençais j'allais toujours dans la
même direction
j'habitais d'avoir à rouler et de perdre
du temps je m'étais adjoint à une petite
équipe qui faisait en même temps
descendre un passager d'un côté et mon
père un autre de notre côté et ça
reparte et avant même qu'il ait eu le
temps de s'asseoir il s'essayait au
moment où je décollais c'était un tout
petit tour c'est ce que les gens
voulaient il voulait juste faire un tour
pour voir ce que ça faisait au retour un
quart d'entre eux allaient directement
acheter un autre billet pour repartir
c'était comme les montagnes russes les
petits joueurs ont fait découvrir
l'aviation dans les plus petites villes
même si c'est sous une forme
rudimentaire obligés le public à
l'accepter comme quelque chose de
permanent autre chose ou un truc dont on
s'était juste servi pendant la guerre
certains pilotes de guerre qu'il ne
s'était pas reconverti dans la voltige
avait trouvé un emploi dans le service
postal aérien qui venait de se créer et
avait inauguré ses premiers vols en 1918
la première traversée transcontinental
fut effectuée en 1924 par un ancien
biplan dh 4 de l'armée qui apporta le
courrier de new york à san francisco
volant la nuit quelles que soient les
conditions métérologiques pour respecter
les horaires les premiers pilotes du
service postal aérien paient un lourd
tribut des quarante pilotes engagés au
départ par le service des postes des
états unis seuls neuf était encore de ce
monde
en 1925 l'aviation n'avait pas encore
fêté son 20e anniversaire que la
technologie atteignait de nouveaux
sommets dans le domaine de la sécurité
et de la fiabilité dans les années 20 on
fit des essais pour améliorer les
performances des moteurs des fuselages
et des instruments de bord
l'un des plus prestigieux pilotes
décédés premier temps fut james carroll
gini d'eau little considéré comme un
casse cou c'était en fait un vrai
professionnel lors de la rencontre
internationale schneider d'octobre 1925
il réussit à faire voler un hydravion
r3c 2 à la vitesse de 371
kilomètres/heure s'attribuant ainsi la
victoire en un temps record mais ce
n'est là qu'un des nombreux records de
cet audacieux jeunes pilotes
jimmy doyle et elle faisait partie de
cette nouvelle génération de pilotes qui
ne se contentait pas simplement de volée
il était décidé à utiliser les nouvelles
machines pour pénétrer plus avant dans
ce monde qui était resté si longtemps à
mystère ils étaient décidés à faire ce
qu'aucun homme n'avait jamais fait
fokker t2 fut le premier avion a
traversé les etats-unis sans étape en
1923 de langeland à san diego
les deux pilotes solaire pendant presque
c'était la première fois que l'on
traversé le continent sans état l'année
suivante en 1924 le double à sword
brothers font des deux avions il y en
avait quatre départs qui fit le tour du
monde il est un peu moins de six mois
pour faire ce tour du monde est
effectuée à environ soixante dix étapes
mais il réussit c'était une prodigieuse
réalisation logistique en même temps
qu'un triomphe de l'aviation
en 1926 dix sept ans après que l'amiral
perry eut atteint le pôle nord le
commandant richard green bird et le
pilote floyd bennett décoller sur la
glace avec leur fokker f27 m
ils étaient les premiers à voler au
dessus du pôle
mais la conquête du ciel ne faisait que
commencer bientôt un autre jeune pilote
allait s'élancer dans les airs pour un
vol qui devait changer le destin du
monde
rares sont ceux qui personnifie aussi
bien le caractère joyeux et le mystère
de l'aviation que charles lindbergh avec
son spirit of saint louis en terme de
symbole amber c'était un peu
l'équivalent xxème siècle de ce qu'avait
été daniel bull technology été la grande
force du 20e siècle
et cet homme jeune et intrépide
l'utiliser pour franchir une nouvelle
frontière
c'est comme s'il était monté dans un
avion à la conquête du ciel
l'homme est allé partout où ils
pouvaient c'est aussi simple michael
collins astronautes d'apollo 11
léonard de vinci
quel et les frères wright charles
lindbergh tous ces hommes sont nés à des
époques différentes et se sont servis de
différentes techniques mais ils sont
liés par une fraternité universelle et
intemporelle
au royaume des rêves montée en
montgolfière ou s'élancer du sommet
d'une montagne sur un planeur comme
lilienthal n'est pas si éloigné
d'atteindre le champ d'à côté sur un an
rio ou de traverser l'atlantique sur le
spirit of saint louis l'aspiration est
la même ce mélange étrange de mystère et
de joie de danger et de réussite nous
rappelle que des premiers mythes de
l'humanité
jusqu'au voyage dans les étoiles le rêve
demeure inchangé